so we come now to the topic of induction
which is a standard part of a high
school curriculum and you've probably
seen before but is nevertheless worth
looking at at the level that we look at
things in this class so the idea of
induction can be one way to explain it
is this way suppose that I plan to be
assigning colors to the non-negative
integers like say in this example I
color 0 blue and one red and two blue
and three red and four and five green
and go on it goes on somehow okay now
I'm gonna describe to you a coloring
that I have in mind and we'll see
whether you can figure out what it is
here are the properties that my coloring
has first of all I've colored 0 red and
I've also continued the coloring
satisfying the following rule if I have
an integer that's next to a red integer
then it's red also any integer next to a
red integer is red also so what's my
colorings well you obviously realized
that if they're all red they have to be
and there they are
ok this is actually a statement can be
read as a statement of the rule of
induction it's a kind of a self-evident
axiom about numbers but what's stated
abstractly so first of all what
induction is assuming is that you have
some property of numbers call it red or
an R of 0 you're told and you're also
told that R of 0 implies R of 1 and that
R of 1 implies R of 2 and rf2 implies R
of 3 and in general our event implies R
of n plus 1 and so on so we've written
it out this way as an infinite set of
implications to emphasize that that's
what the rule that I stated that if an
integer is next to a red integer then
its red is shorthand for it's really a
shorthand for this infinite number of
different implications each of which has
to hold in order for you to be able to
apply the rule of induction well what
can you conclude if all of these things
hold well
then you can conclude that zero is red
and one is red and two is red and n is
red and so on okay now of course there's
a more much more concise way to accept
to express both these antecedents above
the line in the conclusion below the
line using quantifiers namely the
antecedents could simply be said by two
predicate formulas R of 0 comma for all
n R of n implies R of n plus 1 that's
really the the summary of what we said
on the first slide that if an integer is
less than a red integer then it's red
that is n plus 1 is next to n if n is
red then n plus 1 is red similarly the
stuff below the line that that R of 0 R
of 1 and so on hold is simply expressed
as for all M R of M holds and this is
the form of the induction rule it's read
that if you've proved R of 0 and you've
proved that for every N R of n implies R
of n plus 1 then you can conclude that
for every M R of M holds where the
variables are all ranging over the
non-negative integers by the way notice
that I used n for the variable name
above the line in the antecedent and M
for the variable line below in the
consequently I can use any names that I
like for bound variables just as in when
you define a procedure you can name the
parameters of the procedure anything you
like because they're local variables and
I've used an M in the bottom and an N in
the top just to emphasize that the that
those are variables have nothing to do
with each other
which is a point that sometimes confuses
all the students ok sometimes the rule
of induction is explained in terms of
dominoes you have all these dominoes
lined up next to each other you knock
one over it knocks over the next one and
so on if that helps you think about and
remember dominoes that's fine ok
let's apply induction maybe one of the
most basic and standard applications
would be to prove a numerical identity
so let's prove one that we've actually
seen before this is the formula that
we've previously proved using the well
ordering principle for the sum of a
geometric geometric sum the sum of R to
the 0 R to the 1 up to R to the N
and the claim is that that's equal to R
to the n plus 1 minus 1 divided by R
minus 1 so this sum of n plus 1 terms
actually can be expressed concisely with
a fairly single a single simple term and
of course this only works if R is not 1
because I can't have the denominator be
0 all right how do we prove it well I'm
gonna do the proof and at the same time
that I do the proof I'm going to show
you a kind of a standard template that
you can pull out and use for induction
proofs so the template it's just an
organizational method to do the proof
I'm doing the the template in magenta so
that's the part that really is form not
substance there's no math in it it's
just the structure that we're gonna
organize the proofs in at least in the
beginning so here we go the first thing
you do is tell your reader that you're
going to be using proof by induction
that helps him understand what's coming
so you'll begin with the line proof by
induction on n now n is not in magenta
because sometimes you use different
variables and sometimes there'll be many
variables in the assertion so you need
to tell the reader just which one is the
one then you're going to be applying
induction to alright that said the most
important part of the proof the proof
the part that where there's usually a
mistake if there's a mistake anywhere
it's usually in the absence of the
statement of an induction hypothesis or
a misguided induction hypothesis so the
next part of the template says the
induction hypothesis P of n is and in
this case our induction hypothesis is
that this equality holds that's what
we're trying to prove so the induction
hypothesis is P of n the objective then
implicitly then when we're doing
induction with this induction hypothesis
is to prove that for all n P of n halts
this identity works for all non-negative
integers and ok
having stated the induction hypothesis
the first thing we have to do is work on
the base case that is proof it for N
equals 0 now we're telling the reader
that it's N equals 0 because sometimes
it's convenient to start at N equals 1
or N equals 2 and then you're just
concluding that the property holds for
all and greater than equal to 1 or
however all N greater than equal to
wherever you store
so we're gonna start at zero which is
the standard place and what do we have
to check we have to check that the sum
on the left when n goes to it when n is
zero is equal to the sum to the formula
on the right when n is zero well the sum
on the left when n is zero it's really
just 1 because it's going from R to the
0 to R to the 0 the R and the R squared
they're a little misleading because
they're not really there when n is 0 so
the left hand side is 1 and the right
hand side is r minus 1 over R minus 1
which is 1 since R is not 1 so sure
enough it checks and we're okay the case
N equals 0 has now been proved so the
next thing we have to do in the template
is to go to the inductive step and
that's where we assume that P of n holds
and we roll out to use the the P of n
assumption in order to prove that P of n
plus 1 holds we're the only thing that
we know about n besides that P of n
holds is that n is greater than or equal
to 0 and our proof has to work for all
possible n that are greater than or
equal to 0
all right well now we can start doing
the non template math that has to do
with the content of what we're actually
trying to prove this is what I want to
prove this is P of n plus 1 it's gotten
by replacing the ends in the previous
equation by n plus ones I'd like to have
that be ok
how do I get to that well I can assume P
of n which is kind of looks like it
already it's a good head start on
getting to B of n plus 1 so I'm allowed
to assume that this equality holds for n
I don't know what n is except that it's
a non-negative integer but this equality
holds for n and I have to prove that it
holds for n plus 1 well if you look at
this what I'm trying to prove is
something about the some that goes up to
R to the n plus 1 so given this equation
I can turn the left hand side into the
sum that I'm interested in that is the
sum of powers of are up to the n plus
first power of our simply by adding R to
the n plus 1 to both sides
an obvious strategic move or tactical
okay so doing that I get this equality
which I've now proved from the induction
hypothesis namely the sum up to R to the
N plus 1 which is what I'm interested in
is equal to this algebraic expression on
the right hand side and if I'm lucky and
of course I will be the right-hand side
is gonna simplify to be the target
expression with n replaced by n plus 1
so what happens is let's put R to the n
plus 1 over this common denominator R
minus 1 and I get the second term and
then you can do a little bit of
algebraic simple a simplification
trivial and you'll realize that sure
enough it simplifies to R to the n plus
1 plus 1 minus 1 over R minus 1 which
was exactly the equality that I was
hoping to prove so in fact at this point
we can say that we've proved P of n plus
1 and we've completed the induction
proof we're done okay that is the first
basic example of an induction proof and
the whole template is now visible except
maybe there should have been a QED or a
done statement all right by the way as
an aside and we already saw a little
problem with this the three dots that
appeared in the sum are called an
ellipsis plural is ellipses and they are
used where the the writer is trying to
tell the reader that there's an obvious
pattern that the reader is expected to
see which i think is fairly clear in
this case you go you know it's R to the
0 R to the 1 part of it 2 out of the 3
up to R to the N the difficulty is that
sometimes the the the ellipsis can cause
some confusion for example we have to
figure out that when n is 0 the
left-hand side actually just meant 1
it was just R to the 0 so the R and the
R squared weren't really there one way
to really avoid that kind of fencepost
problem and that where you've shown in
order to make clear what the pattern is
you've shown more than it may then more
of pattern and may may always be there
is to use a precise mathematical
notation where I actually tell you the
pattern of the ice term and tell you
that you should sum from I equals 0 to n
so the Sigma notation is shorthand for
some and I'm telling you that the ice
term in the sum is r to the AI and it's
going to run from I equals 0 to n so
this is a sort of mathematical notation
for a for loop for a do loop do from I
equals 0 to n add R to the I plus r to
the I to the accumulator and some
notation is certainly more precise but
sometimes it's actually harder to read
than simply showing you the pattern
because the pattern often is visible
visually ok now let me tell you a little
story and some made-up story but it's
kind of fun to tell this is the familiar
building this data center and this is
actually a design mock-up that the
architects produced for the MIT team
that was overseeing the construction and
design of the building to show what the
student lobby would look like the
students Street now the story goes that
what part of the plan for the students
Street was to have a plaza that was
gonna be a built out of unit size
squares but an uncertain number of them
there was gonna be a parameter that
determined the size of the square and
the square the size of the square was
actually gonna be a power of 2 by a
power of 2 made out of unit sized tiles
so there would be 2 to the N times 2 to
the N unit size tiles filling up this
plot this square plaza and the plaza was
to be tiled with these unit tiles but
one tile space was to be left blank so
that the statue of a what was then in
the potential donor bill could be placed
in the middle as an incentive for him to
donate funds for the completion of the
building which indeed he did so the
puzzle then was put forward by the
architect Frank Gehry who many regard is
after Frank Lloyd Wright is the greatest
architect of the 20th century
Gary specified for aesthetic reasons
that he wanted the the square to be
tiled with l-shaped tiles that were made
out of three unit squares he thought
that that would give a pretty design it
actually does so here's an example of
tiling the N equals three case two to
the two cubed equals eight by eight
plaza with bill in the middle there is
that the 8 by 8 plaza tiled with these
l-shaped tiles each consisting of three
unit tiles so the question was the the
exact size of the square was to be
determined by other architectural
considerations so it was parameterised
by n it's going to be 2 to the n by 2 to
the N question was can you always find
such a tiling no matter how big the
square is and leave bill in the middle
well let's try to prove it by induction
the induction hypothesis of Kronik prove
a theorem that for any 2 to the N by 2
to the n plaza we can make bill and
Frank happy that is Bill's happy when
he's in the middle and Frank is happy
when it the rest of the square is
covered with l-shaped
tiles by the way middle is a little bit
ambiguous because there are really four
middle squares but of course it doesn't
matter which one you fill cause if you
wanted a different one you could just
rotate the whole Square and get any one
of the four middle squares empty for the
bill statue okay so an induction proof
would proceed by induction on something
or other and the obvious thing is the
end that's in the statement of the
theorem and the induction hypothesis
would straightforwardly be that we can
tile the 2 to the N by 2 to the end
plaza with bill in the middle okay the
base case is N equals 0 that's a 2 to
the 1 by 2 to the 1 it's a 1 by 1 square
ok well not a problem
you just put bill in the 1 Square and
you tile the rest with no l-shaped piles
that fits the rules base case and equals
1 N equals 0 is covered all right so now
we come to the double sized square the
square that sub sized
to the n plus 1 by 2 to the n plus 1 I
have to tile that with bill in the
middle but I have a fairly powerful
induction hypothesis that I'm allowed to
assume namely that I can tile the half
size square that 2 to the N by 2 to the
N square and get bill in the middle
so obviously the double size square is
made out of four half sized squares and
so I can try to fill up the whole square
that's through the whole full size
squared or double size square to the n
plus 1 by 2 to the n plus 1 by working
with my ability to tile them with L
shape tiles leaving bill in the middle
for each of those 4 sub squares so I can
assume that and now I'm stuck really
well what do i do how do I use this
ability to put bill in the middle of
each of those four quadrants in order to
color to fill in the whole thing with in
shape tiles I'm stuck and oh the point
in this example is to show you the way
to get unstuck which is if unexpected
I'm actually gonna get unstuck by
proving something stronger I'm actually
gonna prove that we can find a tiling
using L shaped squares with bill placed
in any specified square that you like
wherever you want to put them I can tile
the rest without shape tiles and leave
the specified single square blank for
bill to be inserted for a statue of bill
to be put there
so what's unintuitive about this is that
I'm proving something stronger than
would it be harder to prove right
but because the I'm trying to prove a
conclusion that's stronger I also have a
stronger induction hypothesis to work
with in conducting the proof and the
neck proof actually as you'll see is
going to be easier so let's do it with
the stronger induction hypothesis the
theorem is again for any to the N by 2
the implies that we can make Bill and
Frank happy proof by induction on n but
with the revised induction hypothesis
I'm calling a P of n again which is I
can
pile the square with bill anywhere so
the base case n equals zero is the same
as before it's just one by one so I put
bill in the only pile that there is
which is both the middle and in the
corner and everything else and the base
case doesn't change for the inductive
step now I have a more powerful thing
that I can assume is the induction
hypothesis I can assume that in any
given square of a 2 to the N by 2 to the
N any given tile location units square
of a 2 to the N by 2 to the n plaza I
can tile the rest with el-sheikh squares
and get bill where I wanted them to be
and I have to use that hypothesis to
show that I can get bill anywhere that's
required in a 2 to the n plus 1 by 2 to
the n plus 1 square so suppose that we
want a tile bill in that designated
arbitrary square of the 2 to the n plus
1 by 2 to the n plus 1 Plaza where we
happen to choose a location where bill
is in the upper right quadrant in the
upper right half size square all right
so by hypothesis I can fill in the
purple square that that quadrant with L
shape tiles leaving bill in that in the
place that he's supposed to be well
here's the trick with the other three
since I can tile them with bill anywhere
I'm gonna tile them with bill in the
respective corners of those 3 other sub
squares which meet in the center of the
full size plaza as shown here and having
done that now it's obvious how to fill
up the whole 2 to the n plus 1 by 2 to
the n plus 1 Plaza because I pull those
four separate pieces together to form
the full size 2 to the n plus 1 by 2 to
the n plus 1 Plaza and look I just put
an l-shaped tile in the middle to fill
up those 3 corner bills and I'm done and
the proof is complete we have just
proved by induction that you need you
can tile any power of 2 by power of 2
square putting leaving bill wherever you
want them and
arrest filled with l-shape tiles now
notice that a part of this process
actually is implicitly defining a
recursive procedure to actually do the
tiling if you watch the way the proof
went if I was going to write a recursive
procedure to do the tiling what I would
do is say okay you give me input n plus
1 which are the dimensions the
specification of the dimensions of the
plaza input n plus 1 or input n means
it's 2 to the N by 2 to the N how do I
do that well you tell me where you want
bill to be as another parameter and then
I will call myself recursively on for
half-size squares so that is call myself
to do squares with dimension parameter
and minus 1/4 times for each quadrant
each time specifying in those quarters
where I want bill to be the recursive
procedure will return a l-shaped tiling
of those four pieces and then on I take
those fit them together and tile that
middle and I wind up with a tiling of
the whole region so what I've just
talked through is the description of a
very easily written recursive procedure
that would print out a picture of an
l-shaped tiling given as input any
number n and that's in fact how we got
the the 8x8 tiling although we did it by
hand rather than writing a program and
that's enough of 2 examples of basic
mathematical induction